welcome back to the david pakman show i
am farron cousins in for david pakman
today you can find me on youtube at
youtube.com
farron balanced you can also find me on
the big youtube channel youtube.com
the ring of fire and of course i'm on
twitter instagram and facebook at farren
balanced
so we talked about the good news
in the first segment today
and that may be all the good news we
have because now it's time to really get
into the nitty-gritty nutty
stories
of this week
and one of those stories
we hit on earlier this week when donald
trump announced that he was suing
new york's attorney general leticia
james because he believes or at least
his lawyers attempt to argue
that the investigation into him and his
company in new york is somehow
unconstitutional
yes unconstitutional to conduct your
constitutional duties as investigators
but that's not it
that's not all that happened
because after the lawsuit was announced
donald trump
decided it would be a sound legal
strategy
to issue a statement and openly attack
and mock
new york attorney general leticia james
here is what donald trump had to say in
his statement and this is a long one so
bear with me
tell leticia that she is not dealing
with the cuomo brothers a corrupt
governor in a corrupt state including
your office and others and fredo who did
the governor's dirty work for him
despite many years of investigation that
nobody else could have survived even if
they did things just slightly wrong
yours is just a continuation of the
political witch hunt that has gone on
against me by radical left democrats for
years
this is not about delay this is about
our constitution
you are nothing but a corrupt official
doing the dirty work of your party you
should not be in office
this could well be the reason you were
just rejected by the people of new york
and your inept run for governor you
didn't quit for a higher purpose you
quit because your poll numbers were
atrocious you didn't have a chance new
york got lucky
now
i've never been under criminal
investigation um i've never been
arrested
you know i've never really uh been on
the wrong side of the law
in terms of things like this so
i don't know
but i'm willing to bet
after working with the best lawyers in
this country for more than 17 years
that openly
and repeatedly
mocking and antagonizing the person
doing the investigating
uh
probably not the smartest legal strategy
out there i'm just go i'm not a lawyer
right i didn't go to law school
but i'm willing to bet that's probably
not what you should do and i have to
imagine that trump's lawyers were
sitting there after this statement came
out
just probably in shock thinking to
themselves oh my god
oh lord what is going to happen now and
then of course probably being happy like
wait a minute this probably means we get
to work a little bit longer and
therefore you know we'll get paid more
money so hey it's a win for us
but oh my god this is going to be so
difficult to defend now
like i can't imagine that these lawyers
actually signed off
on trump's attack against the
investigator this is the woman who holds
your fate in her hand
you know i'm willing to bet based on
what we already know from documents that
are already publicly available
that she probably has enough information
to at least charge you with something
right now
whether it sticks or not is irrelevant
but she could make your life hell
by go ahead going ahead and filing
charges at least for what's happening up
in westchester right we got those docs
we know what you told the city your
property was worth and we know what you
reported on your financial disclosure
forms as president those two numbers
could not be more different
so i think she could go ahead and
probably pop you for tax fraud right now
you know just to kind of get the ball
rolling
and as i discussed the other day you
know about this whole political witch
hunt thing
one i think he knows something big is
about to happen and he's trying to get
ahead of it he's trying to go ahead and
uh
plant the seeds of doubt
with his base with his followers
so that way when it finally breaks he
can say see i told you total political
witch hunt
but the second thing
that already disproves the witch hunt
theory
is that they've they found some witches
you know
weisselberg has been charged the trump
organization itself
has been charged
okay those are very real criminal
charges against these two groups so you
can't sit there and try to say that oh
this is all fake nobody listened to it
nobody pay attention
it's absolutely just out to get me for
political purposes well
even if that were true which it's not
the fact that they found crimes
would in fact justify
their political witch hunt would it not
but all of this you know trump kind of
gave up the game in his statement like
this isn't about delay all right so
because of that we now know this is
totally about delay
and i think the delay that he wants to
have happen
is he wants this investigation
one to slow down that's what his
lawsuit's about
so that way after the midterms
assuming republicans when actually it
doesn't matter if republicans win but
after the midterms that's when trump is
likely according to his closest people
to announce that he is in fact running
for president again in 2024
he doesn't want to make this
announcement prior to the midterms
because he doesn't want to be blamed if
things go sideways for the republicans
so if the republicans win he's going to
come out and say listen you won because
of me therefore i'm running for
president if they lose he's going to say
you lost because i wasn't there
therefore i am running for president
then once he announces he is running for
president he is going to try to use that
oh you can't prosecute me because i'm a
candidate
uh i've got executive privilege again
even though i'm just a candidate that's
what he's going for
wait it out as long as possible try to
delay it
with this ridiculous lawsuit he filed
and of course in the meantime antagonize
the very people
who could ultimately end up sending you
to prison
which again
poor legal strategy but
it's trump we're dealing with so
you know
you can't hope to control him you can
only try to contain him every now and
then
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below